what do you get when you mix the
pharmaceutical industry with the profit
motive something good or something evil
I think there are people who are truly
evil who don't care about human life as
long as they get their money at this
rally in downtown Los Angeles protesters
sent it off against the role of profits
in the health care industry health are
just like firefighting or schools it's
not the proper making adventure all the
corporations want to do is cheat to win
that's not the great American Way the
great American Way is where we know
there are rules in the game we play
within the rules and the best one wins
good point drug companies hire armies of
lobbyists to bend the rules in their
favor and that is a lot like cheating
but many protesters seem to be offended
by the very idea of profit disgusting
this should be no profit in health care
and what do you say to people who think
that profits are good thing that it
drives innovation well I don't know you
can see people eating out of garbage
cans over here and see how that makes
you feel I didn't it's kind of sick so
all I could say to that protester is
take it out of politics I get passionate
because it's like go if you want a
protest go protest on once you do a
three-day breast cancer walk and raise
money Dave Christensen is a construction
superintendent who lives in San Diego
with his wife and two daughters I was
riding my bike a lot training surfing
and ridin and but i really was starting
to get a passion for cycling being you
know the competitive juices were flowing
i've always been that type of a guy but
christensen realized something strange
he was training hard but he wasn't
improving i was riding bikes a lot and
training and I just kept slower and
slower and weaker and weaker and tired
and what's his mass on my throat and I
better work harder I started riding at
night with lights on I'm getting slower
soon after his doctor would tell him why
he was getting slower and he said okay
you have cancer and so at first you you
know at first right away I was like
you're overwhelmed and then I started a
crock you know I was like holy cow
Christensen would have to endure
chemotherapy his cancer non-hodgkins
lymphoma was grown fast he told his
daughter he was going to survive it I'm
really close with my dad and it was like
really hard I know you picture you to
Avenue a little like never get sick
eventually Christensen's grief
transformed into something else I
started getting mad and I basically told
myself cancer you picked the wrong
person he drew inspiration from Lance
Armstrong cyclist and cancer survivor I
can't ride my bike as fast as lance but
if he can kick cancers butt I can kick
cancers butt but is America the best
place to kick cancers but every other
democracy in the world has a healthcare
system that covers everybody and we
don't America is the only industrialized
country that doesn't have a national
health plan after all we're often
reminded of how unusual America is all
of the modern industrial nations have
some sort of universal health care
program Britain Canada the message
unlike compassionate Canada America is a
cruel and where profits come before
people saying that fundamentally
misunderstands what the function of
profit is the profit mechanism is a
great motivator nadeem esme love
canada's fraser institute when you have
a system like Canada's where you're
controlling the price of patented drugs
where you're restricting access to
medical technologies in order to control
costs you're really not creating a
marketplace where a company can come in
and sell their innovation the profit
which then encourages them to make more
innovation I have no sympathy for the
truck companies they make a ridiculous
amount of money but even some doctors
like this family physician who attended
the LA rally scoff at what the profit
motive has helped produce they haven't
really done anything out innovative in
the last 20 or 30 years as well the last
truly innovative drug was Prozac but
wouldn't the drug companies point to
things like cholesterol-lowering drugs
or HIV drugs stents those those are
those are innovative drugs and there is
a role for them look at where recent
innovations have come from and many of
the most important innovations of our
generation MRIs CT scans
and cholesterol-lowering statins were
all developed in America same for the
innovation that's most important to the
Christians and family and it's called on
rituxan although it was still in
clinical trials at the time Christensen
psychologist added the promising new
drug to his treatment regimen I feel
Rituxan saved my life Christensen's
cancer is in remission thanks to his
positive attitude his oncologist and
rituxan which was created by a san
diego-based biotech company in a way
we're very much free riding in canada on
the innovation in the united states
allowing American healthcare consumers
to fund all of the innovation and then
buying it up here for Canada why can
Canada keep drug prices artificially low
because the pharmaceutical companies
know that they can make a profit in the
United States this is why you for the
most part don't see drug companies doing
their innovative work in foreign markets
it used to be difference as Joe Panetta
president of the biotech Association bio
calm most of the innovative drugs 20
years ago were developed in Europe they
weren't developed here but with the
greater nationalization of healthcare in
Europe and with price controls being
placed on drugs drug companies for the
most part of move to the US that means
Americans usually get new drugs faster
than patients in nations like Canada you
have cancer you want to be in the United
States and better access means Americans
have a better shot of surviving horrible
diseases it's a form of predatory
capitalism on the expense of those who
are sick and dying it's all about profit
it's all about money but many complain
about high profits and the high price of
prescription drugs there's a lot of
people that are around and available to
complain about the high price of the
prescription drugs because of those
prescription drugs we went to this
biotech conference to find out why new
drugs cost so much twenty nine out of
ten things fail the one that does
succeed you have to be able to make
money on otherwise you can't fund the
other nine failures the average drug
that hits the market takes about 12 to
15 years of development about a billion
dollars they have to recuperate all that
money spent
presentations are given by reps from
small biotech companies hoping to find
investors for emerging medical
innovations that would treat conditions
like diabetes and heart disease if the
money is not there to drive innovation
that innovation will not appear
developing a medical innovation is every
bit as grueling as training for the tour
de france yet we're not outraged when
lance armstrong makes millions but
somehow it's offensive if people get
rich making life-saving drugs dave
christensen cancer survivor glad to be
here for all those whose lives may one
day be saved like future innovations
let's hope America isn't shamed into
following the lead of the rest of the
world there should be no profit in
healthcare drug makers who take big
risks may make big profit but I say good
for them in fact if they're saving lives
I hope they make a killing for reason TV
i'm nick gillespie
but you can't go changing every
you feel like changing
I wish I was just like you